i'm going to make a brief introduction
for for our next speaker
well we have a ramiro carlo
now
ramiro carlo is a senior data scientist
for mercado libre the biggest e-commerce
site in latin america has plenty of
experience working with data in
different industries such as oil
consulting and energy now we are going
to have the session called why you when
you can trust your labels this is an
approach this is a practical a approach
so let's welcome ramiro carlo
you can go ahead ramiro
hello the this is what to do when you
can trust your labels
in this
talk we're going to try to
tell you about our experience
working with
label data and how we can build label
data sets using
different sources of information and
different learning methods
right
um
well um
i was already presented so my name is
ramirez i'm not going to spend too much
time here like i say i'm that the
science of mercado libre to give you
some
context mercado libre it's uh
e-commerce site because in latin america
we
currently
have
almost
65 millions buyers and more than 12
million sellers each each month
so
as you can see on all this
movement of people and proud we have
many pros that we don't want to make it
to the marketplace so in our team we're
basically
working detecting and moderating any
product that by country legislation or
internal policy cannot be published on
the site
this is a highly unbalanced
classification we have more than 80
48 policies that we must identify
we receive
more than 4 million requests every day
and we also have like an adversarial
component in our system that we have
players and
that will try to fool our system
continuously so we need to be
like a very
uh proficient identifying these new
patterns of behavior and and introduce
them to the model
for example in this case this
title is in portuguese
but you can say the
they introduce
the name of an abortive drug here
mask as a tire
publication
so in this case we need have the
information on the title
but in other cases like the one i show
you here
the title have no information about
the drug
we only can identify this if we
if we check the pictures
and
even more
if we keep going on time there are some
publications like this that is supposed
to be a fabric
the title doesn't give you give us any
information
or
the pictures neither so we need to check
like the product variations in this case
the design
to identify that the seller is trying to
sell an aborted drug
so
we want to talk about labels so a good
question is
where labels come from
um when i mention this is because
sometimes we assume that the machine
learning problem is defined
within the data itself
like all we need to solve this problem
is already there
and this is rarely the case
um normally when we start a machine
learning
problem this is not defined by the data
we usually get an unstructured
definition like a document or some set
of rules or some technical specification
and we must take
this information
and start building our labels based on
that so one idea that i want to leave
here is labels needs to be constructed
they are not just there for taking we
need to build them
so to build them we need information we
need
methods
so
how we use and integrate this
information available to generate the
labels
is a fundamental step in the design and
planning of any machine learning system
if we have a perfect model where our
labels are not properly done the impact
that this model will have in the real
world is not going to be the one that we
desire
so in our case for the moderation of
products
we have like
information for the positive class which
is the
the prohibited one
we have the documentation the rules of
procedures of the site
we need some reports and announces from
users they use a platform and we need
some heuristic and business rules that
would previously implemented
like mainly basis on rejects or
seller behavior
some of them we were
manually revised another were not
on in the other side for the negative
class
it's all the active publication on the
site right
and another special case is the robot
moderations which are cases um that were
initially wrongly
moderated and then the seller contact us
and request to be
put back on the marketplace so in these
cases we have a friction with the seller
and this is one of the cases we're
trying to avoid
so within information how we can build
the labels well
we can use many methods now we're going
to talk about manual labeling
active learning with learning semi
supervised
these three
last there is a lot of theory
for this we are not trying to go into
that the idea here is to have an idea a
motivation for them so we can know when
to use each and how which is the one
that fits better to or or problem
so uh at the beginning of
this design
um
we put us an objective to moderate as
much as we can but
minimize
the amount of
hello
but minimize
the amount of
friction with the sellers
so
to
measure it we have a
rollback rate which is the amount of
claims
versus the amount of moderation that we
do ratio
and also we have a
manual precision which is uh
derived from uh
from a humanly review sample
so this are the consideration that we
take at the beginning
so the first step that we in the first
step of the offer process we decided to
only use
manual review
information
so
why do we choose to use only
manual first because we have the
greatest precision
and simply because we can make a
factibility
check
so usually the first step with the
machine learning problem
could be not using machine learning at
all so we need to see if a person can
can differentiate the problem in this
case it was very obvious but this is not
always the case
uh but we need that we can and like
different people will come up to the
same result
uh on the front side of course this is
very resource intensive both in time and
people
right so it doesn't
scare well to to a lot of date
so
we set up a
moderation system we work like this
um like you can see
um
or we cannot
check all of um
all of uh
or moderations
so
some of them are gonna act automatically
and some of them are gonna be sent to a
human agent for review
so the first decision that we must take
is uh which one we send for moderate for
for review and which one we're gonna
directly act
so
in this case we use a
criteria
a method known as
active learning in this case we still
use
manual labeling
but we try to prioritize the items that
provide the greatest amount of
information to the problem
so how we do that
well
[Music]
we start with a random sample
then
we
label that and train and evaluate one or
many models
and from those models we
generate a priority score
so
how do we generate the score well there
is many methods
most of them are based on
or centenity
in our case
we use
we just
the difference is called of the
different classes to calculate the
entropy
so this will give you an indication of
how close are to the decision boundary
and we choose to prioritize those but we
could easily take for example many
models and select those which is the
greatest amount of disagreement
within the the models
or we can choose to combine them and use
some kind of exploration exploitation
criteria
so
after we have this score
basically we sample again but now we
take the
the most valuable cases which are going
to be the ones with the highest priority
and these samples if we if we
choose them wisely we will have much
more information uh and we'll have to
define the classification boundaries um
much more efficiently than if we just
randomly sampled
so what we did is we add this uh
this active learning sample in in the
model workflow
and we start choosing
the the cases with the most value for
human review and the rest we
we just moderated them automatically
um
what are the
the pros of this method well um
the we have a greater amount of
information at each review
[Music]
and it's an iterative process that allow
us to adjust the error certainty
and in the con side well we still depend
on human revision
and sometimes
we could overfit over one decision
boundary we started
comparison to one decision boundary and
sometimes
there are some other areas in the in the
space of
labels that we don't check
uh how we deal with with this
with this
with this model well
the precision was okay
it met expectation but the recall and
and the moderation
shared
uh it was not
so we also have a rapid degradation of
this model and we
were missing some obvious cases like we
said we were only training with the
manually review cases
so these were the the least confident
ones so in some cases
that were very obvious and we didn't we
didn't get them
so the diagnosis was was very clear
clear we need to get more label cases
so
we started looking for them so
what where do we get more labels well
the the most obvious answer was to
incorporate all the automatic detections
that we were doing however doing this
requires like a label validation process
so we need to see if that decision that
we took
we need to add another
confidence label so
lay here
so we can decide if we can incorporate
this to our training process
so
[Music]
how how we validate these labels well in
our case we have a framework of
hypothesis testing and
experimentation
that we can use to generate like weak
label and function from each experiment
these experiments are like
very focused cases like
we
comp we experiment um if
which is the
average stock
of a certain
prohibited case
so
this no doesn't this
don't need to be like super precise
but
we need to complement they need to
provide complementary information
about the the input data right
so with all these different experiments
we can generate a confidence score
and related with the result and the
statistical significance
of the result in that experiment so the
thing that i was talking basically is
the basis of what we call weak
supervision learning which is
incorporating knowledge to the system
using labeling functions we provide like
weak labels that can be combined into
strong predictive models so we use
different
indicators
some are more reliable some less but the
combination of all of them
can give us a a
label candidate and a confidence score
so in this case all the automatic
information which we can have we can put
them through
a set of
labeling functions and decide if they
are reliable enough to include in the
training process
so what we did basically is to put this
in in the system too
and with it allows to is they'll give us
an entry point so each time we have a
new insight about
any information we can incorporate it
very easily in each retraining to the to
the system
um
so
the pros for for this approach for this
step
is we have an automatic we have higher
volume it's faster and it's cheaper
because
we
we don't require to have someone
constantly checking
this
this process
we have a confidence score for for each
case that can be used to parameterize
the system or to
set the threshold for different
levels of reliability
and also allows to incorporate new
domain knowledge to the to the system
very easily
so in the other hand labels still have a
lower confidence and manually review
cases
and also labeling functions can be a way
to introduce biases to a system we have
to be very careful how we define them
and
what information we use
because
we can end up introducing
dangerous bias to our data
so
we apply all these
techniques
and we managed to increase the amount of
prohibited product cases in the other
set in a temple
also all the hypotheses and experiments
we we made help us to
value will give us very very valuable
information for the future selection
and with all this information
we generate a new model
and we train with much uh more complete
and uh
data sets and much more wider range of
cases
um
so well now
and this were the the result of this
retraining and redesign of the
of the cases the moderation share we
call this metric is
how many of the
moderations done all across the site
were done by your system scd is the name
internal name of the
of the model so we started in
2020 with just two and a half percent
with only manual the revised data
and
then we implemented the active learning
criteria we
went to eight and then after
implementing
all the weak learners and
the data automatic data validation
our models start to gain in a lot of
traction so we multiply by six the
amount of moderation we made and so we
end up
participating with the 45 percent of all
moderations on inside
and all
in this time we managed to keep a
rollback rate very controlled between
two and three percent
so
um done having done all this stuff um
we can say that we can already trace all
labels right
well not
not
not yet
so
in this so far we've been talking about
generating new labels but we can also
use all these methods for for validating
them to quality check
if for labels uh
uh we can trust
so for example in
2020 um
this mercado libre allow
a cross boarding trading service which
is basically sellers can from different
countries
can
can send
products to another one
so
mainly we have a great influence of
sellers mainly from from china and
countries in indonesia with
great production
rates and availability so
all these new sellers have new behaviors
we need to capture
and for example we noticed that one
policy that
didn't use to be very important start
became a very dominant moderation policy
so
we adapt we retrain we use this data to
to adjust our model
but we find out that even if we were
constantly moderating this category
there was almost no robux requested by
any seller
and the
the volume of modulation in one point it
was like 75 percent only this category
which was a little bit strange
so
we need to analyze it
a little bit
deeply
so
when we check them we
we found out that most sellers were
using
automated script to publish these
products
and they never contact customer service
so we can
moderate or we can
cancel all their publications they will
start
still didn't complain about anything
so when we
review and we calculate the real
precision on that policy we found out
that it was around 17
so
um
very very low so in this case
luckily we have uh
we could introduce a new set of rules
in this case like we say before the the
weak learning instead of using to
generate new labels we start using them
to
validate
all all moderation so
a lot of things that were moderated it
shouldn't have been
so
we
define a new set of rules just to
exclude those cases from
from the training process because we
were perpetrating these errors
so in these cases we we show
how quickly we can introduce new
information to the system in a quite
robust way
uh just defining a new set of rules for
a different group of products in this
case the cross boarding
uh cross-border trading product
um
also this when this happens we start
[Music]
suspecting that the same
the same phenomenon could be happening
in
in with the other policies too
so
sorry to interrupt you just a kind
reminding we still have five minutes
more actually until now there are no
questions from our participants so you
can go ahead with your you can continue
with your presentation
okay thank you
um so
we try to
find or say we decided we need to go
after undetected false positives
so we can
we can minimize this uh under under
reporting
of false of wrongly modulated cases
so what we did
is we use the rollback that we have and
we try to pivot around them and framed
this as a semi supervised learning
problem
to
to find
cases that were similar to drawbacks but
they were not reported
so
same is
so like i said we frame it as a
semi-supervised learning
which is a method that allows us to
combine a small amount of label data
with a large amount of unlabeled data
that will help us to
to
discover or to understand the underlying
distribution
so
in these cases
um
we we need to have uh
we need
to have data that is uh
that complies with certain assumptions
like continuity assumptions cluster or
manifold
these are related to that
similar
representations of the product we have a
higher probability of having this the
same label
so
we we use this
when we try in using all the universe of
publications available inside
we didn't have good results but then we
reduced the sample space
to
only automatic moderations
we changed the representations of the
products
to a
simpler
representation and also we try using
different different similarity
measurements
so
introducing all these modifications
uh we managed to to find a very good
solution and to find this unreported
false positive
and
and incorporated this to the workflow so
we maximize the the impact
of of each
of each rollback
and we introduce
this to the
to the flow so it won't work online so
now we have a weak learning validation
and then we have a semi supervised uh
detector of of potentially
of
yeah of potentially drawbacks in the
future
so
applying all this method we went again
and check the
the quality of the measurement and
find out after implementing all these
techniques and all this validation
process
we this policy that was so dominant and
we have
very very bad
precision we move it from 15 to 40 from
to 83 of precision
the overall precision of the system went
from 43 to 72
and we only decrease the amount of
modulations that we perform on a 10
percent
which was a very very small price to pay
for for that bump in in
in
precision right
so well this is uh all i wanted to tell
you i hope this would be useful or
interesting for you
and if you have any questions i'll be
available on islam
thank you very much